Christian Drummond joins us live from
the event with more on what's being
dubbed shade a Kristin Kirsten yes it is
shade a we are at a strip mall on the
corner of Sahara and Jones where as you
can see here the community has come out
to show their support for officer che
Mik aloneness the officer who was shot
while on duty nearly two weeks ago
we have seen a steady stream of
supporters throughout the day coming
here and while they're standing in line
they're getting the chance to sign a
get-well shade banner which will be
given to his family at the end of the
day and I'm actually here with Shay
stepfather
Patrick Neville thank you so much and I
know the question many people keep
asking you how is Shay doing right now
in the hospital well I'm gonna do this
because I'm social distancing with you
guys
Shay is so critical I mean he's on a
ventilator
and you know right now we're just
praying and hoping and this event helps
to get Shay up to the next level of care
that we can get him to shares awake he
appears to know who his family is which
is very important to us and you know our
just concerned is to move him forward to
that next level what does it mean to see
all of this support throughout the day
people wanting to help Shay with that
road to recovery I can't say enough I
mean words I can never say can describe
how I feel and how the family feels when
you come out here and this has been
going out all day and you see people
standing out 105 degree temperature for
a long periods of time that shows a
commitment and a strength and community
that makes Las Vegas great so it makes
us move forward it makes you know Shay's
fighting and to see the community
fighting for Shay is so important to us
how will this help with his road to
recovery at the moment
well just that the outpouring of support
has been great because it's actually you
know it gives you that momentum to keep
moving forward but to be honest with you
this is expensive long-term care for
Shay and I don't look at his money
because it's really hard to do that but
the funds we raise here today go
directly to Shay in his medical care
that he has years and years of that
ahead of them wishing for the best
hoping for the best and still praying of
course we are and when you see what the
community has done the support that
we've got from the community from the
University Medical Center for the
injured police officer from from Metro
themselves it speaks volumes to the
community I live in I've lived here
since 1985 and I've never seen anything
this tremendous and I just say we
appreciated Shay's family and I know
Shay would definitely appreciate it
community rallying around your family
and again this event will be going on
through five o'clock today everyone's in
line right now to get a t-shirt one of
these which are 20 dollars for adults
$10 for children and if you can't make
it out to the event today we have a link
on our website 8 News now.com where you
can go and make a donation and then come
Monday again if you cannot buy one of
the t-shirts today these will be up on
the injured police officers fund website
again go to our website 8 News now.com
for more information
reporting live Kristin Drummond V news
now thank you so much Kristen and so
great to see our community it's a very
special